c'est l'heure du journal de l'afrique
soyez les bienvenus
à la une ce soir en tunisie rached
ghannouchi fait de la résistance le chef
du parlement rejette la dissolution de
l'assemblée décidé hier par le président
taïs ayedh les députés frondeurs sont
bien décidés à poursuivre leur activité
en guinée ibrahima kassory fofana
désigné président provisoire du rpg arc
en ciel le parti d'alpha condé la
convention s'est tenue ce jeudi à
conakry sa candidature ne faisait
pourtant pas l'unanimité les
explications de notre correspondant dans
ce journal
et puis il nous fait découvrir à
madagascar autrement à travers son
regard et ses clichés le photographe
richard solo a été
récompensé par le world press photo pour
sa série la guerre du zébu déjà solo est
l'invité du journal de l'afrique
c'est une décision nulle et non avenue
et contraire la constitution les mots de
rached ghannouchi le chef du parlement
tunisien refuse de se plier à la
décision du président ça y est de
dissoudre l'assemblée le bras de fer se
poursuit donc entre le chef de l'état et
son principal opposant le chef du parti
d'inspiration islamiste ennahda les
tunisiens eux semblent désabusés par
cette crise politique laurent verser
cher
un parlement barricadé symbole d'un bras
de fer au sommet de l'état qui menace de
faire vaciller la démocratie tunisienne
au lendemain des annonces du président
kaïs sayyed de nombreux tunisiens disent
ne plus faire confiance à une classe
politique par laquelle ils ne se sentent
pas représentés
les élus ne pensent qu'à leurs propres
intérêts il décide ensemble sans se
soucier des besoins du peuple
cela fait dix ans qu'ils n'ont rien fait
pour les tunisiens la situation est
devenue intenable à cause de la hausse
des prix et du coup de la ville
la crise s'amorce en juillet dernier
lorsque kyle sayed annonce la suspension
du parlement
quelques mois plus tard il officialise
ses pleins pouvoirs à travers des
mesures exceptionnelles s'accordant
notamment le droit de légiférer par
décrets
mercredi une centaine de députés
décident de braver l'interdiction et
organise une séance virtuel lors de
laquelle ils votent contre les pouvoirs
renforcés du président
quelques heures plus tard qu'à issaïev
dénonce une tentative de coup d'état est
dissout le parlement
une décision que rached ghannouchi chef
du parlement et du parti d'opposition et
nardin refuse de reconnaître
[Musique]
nous considérons que le parlement reste
en activité et la tunisie est encore
vivante et elle doit rester comme ça
selon la constitution
alors que ses dirigeants s'affronter
campent sur leurs positions
la tunisie continue de s'enliser dans
une impasse politique dont l'issue
semble de moins en moins certaine
au burkina faso l'ultimatum posé par la
cedeao arrive à expiration ce soir la
junte doit libérer le président déchu
roch marc christian kaboré faute de quoi
des sanctions individuelles cibleront
les autorités de transition et bien
selon le porte parole du gouvernement
des concertations sont en cours en vue
d'un transfert de l'ex-président vers
l'une de ces résidences familiales un
dispositif sécuritaire renforcé
il sera mise en place et puis la cedeao
réclame aussi une transition plus rapide
vers un régime démocratique
réponse de la junte ce jeudi la priorité
est le retour de la sécurité donc pour
le délai fixé par la cedeao
puisque le délai
c'est aujourd'hui le gouvernement du
burkina faso ne subi qu'un seul délai
celui de bien faire les choses celui
d'agent c'est son action conformément
aux réalités du terrain en toute
objectivité avec la plus grande prudence
est le plus grand réalisme possible ce
qui nous dicte notre action c'est
vraiment le terrain c'est vraiment
l'opérationnel et c'est le contexte dans
laquelle pendant lequel le burkina faso
est plongée sur la préoccupation liée à
l'ancien président du faso le
gouvernement du burkina faso tient à
rassurer la commission de la cedeao
ainsi que toutes les communautés la
communauté internationale que depuis un
peu plus de trois semaines des
concertations été initiée au niveau
national et se poursuivent dans
l'optique d'aboutir au retour de
l'ancien président dans une résidence
familiale de son choix tout en
garantissant sa sécurité
autre le team à thème de la cedeao cette
fois à la guinée après le coup d'état du
colonel mamadou
bouya contre alpha condé l'agente a
jusqu'au 25 avril pour présenter un
calendrier acceptable en attendant la
vie politique suit son cours le rpg
arc-en-ciel s'est choisi son nouveau
président provisoire lors de sa
convention ce jeudi à conakry il s'agit
d'ibrahima de kassory fofana
368 délégués ont fait le déplacement
avant l'organisation du congrès du parti
plus de détails avec malik diakité notre
correspondant à conakry
sa désignation est sans surprise car il
était le seul candidat déclaré ibrahima
kassory fofana a d'abord été opposant
d'alpha condé avant d'être nommé par
celui-ci premier ministre de 2018
jusqu'à sa chute en septembre dernier
quelques caciques du parti d'anciens
ministres et des représentants du parti
des différents régions du pays se sont
exprimés pour soutenir le choix a dit
ibrahima kassory fofana à la tête du rpg
arc en ciel
ou moins d'être la tête de ce grand
parti et ce quel que soit le temps
qu'elle s'y passait et quelles que
soient les missions que vous me
confirmer que j'aurai y compris accompli
je me sentirai toujours honoré de la
confiance
mais cette désignation est aussi très
contesté par certains responsables et
militants au sein même du parti qui ne
trouve pas cette nomination légitime ils
ont en train de violer les principes et
des textes fondateurs juridique de notre
parti le rpg arc en ciel ils sont dans
l'illégalité et aujourd'hui il veut
passer au forcing c'est un deuxième coup
d'état que le président alpha condé est
en train de subir donc nous ne nous
laisserons pas faire pas du tout
prochaine étape un congrès pour désigner
le futur candidat à la présidentielle en
scrutant qu'il devait avoir lieu après
la période de la transition
en côte d'ivoire le prix de la baguette
est désormais fixée la décision du
gouvernement intervient au moment où les
cours du blé sont en hausse mais aussi
afin de réguler le secteur les
organisations patronales avaient
récemment modifié le poids du pain pour
le prix habituel facturé au consommateur
les explications d'alain de fer gianni
et damien koffi
cela faisait plusieurs mois que les
boulangers ivoirien réclamé une réponse
de l'état face à la montée graduelle des
prix des matières premières le
gouvernement a finalement opté pour un
contrôle plus strict de la baguette par
rapport à son poids 174 et 232 grammes
ce sera entre ces deux fois que le
consommateur ivoirien devra faire son
choix le premier tarif est à 150 francs
cfa quand le second lui a coûté 200
francs selon les autorités s'étaient
jusqu'ici une fourchette qui avaient été
définis pour la baguette standard ce qui
laissait une trop grande marge aux
boulangers en effet il ya quelques jours
certains boulangers ivoiriens avaient
commencé à proposer une baguette plus
petit pour le même prix mais face à
cette mesure certains boulangers et
consommateurs sont insatisfaits selon
eux la solution réside avant tout dans
la subvention de la farine de blé si
jamais il ya encore des modifications au
niveau du prix pour aller encore plus
haut c'est bien sûr bien sûr c'est comme
si on n'a rien faire parce que les
plongeurs continuent encore de souffrir
il paye la matière première plus cher il
faut qu'il en gagne quelque chose mais
je pense que le
le gouvernement doit amortir autre
constat des clients ces nouveaux prix
sont déjà trop élevé pour l'ivoirien
moyen l'an prochain ou bagads ya 105 ans
a touché là on entre là bas tu as
enfants que tout le monde que ça va avec
tout continue d'augmenter il ya plus de
rabais en fait donc qu'ils essaient de
voir un peu le prix de la farine pour
que les boulangers et ceux qui
consomment aussi pu savoir du profit en
un an le prix de la tonne de blé a
doublé dans le pays une flambée qui ne
semble pas prête de s'arrêter
la côte d'ivoire importe une partie de
son blé de russie elle était en juin
2021 le deuxième client de blé tendre
français orieux et royaume uni elle est
là on reste de l'actualité sur le
continent la libération de simples cinq
employés de médecins sans frontières les
employés tchadiens sénégalais on peut y
voir rien et camionnettes libéré au
nigeria un mois après avoir été enlevés
par des hommes armés dans le nord du
cameroun des groupes djihadistes boko
haram itaste à nice en afrique de
l'ouest attaque régulièrement civils et
militaire dans cette région
la visite du chef de la diplomatie
espagnole arabe a annulé elle devait
avoir lieu ce vendredi elle se tiendra
finalement en marge de la visite
officielle du chef du gouvernement
espagnol pedro sanchez au maroc
la date n'a pour le moment pas été
annoncée les deux royaumes ont mis fin
le 18 mars dernier à leur crise
diplomatique liée au statut du sahara
occidental
madrid ayant décidé de se ranger du côté
marocain
une nouvelle force de paix pour la
somalie le conseil de sécurité de l'onu
a voté jeudi
à l'unanimité pour la création d'une
nouvelle force de maintien de la paix de
l'union africaine baptisé à nice elle
vient succéder à l'actuel amisom qui
compte vingt militaires policiers et
civils
et si vous êtes si du côté de dakar vous
pourrez découvrir dès demain 15 oeuvres
de pablo picasso
l'exposition se tient au musée des
civilisations l'artiste a été largement
influencés par les masques et statuettes
du continent nos correspondants sarah
sakho elimane dao ont visité
l'exposition en avant première
mis en regard avec autant d'objets d'art
africain ancien qui aurait pu
l'influencer
l'exposition picasso à dakar rend
hommage à la fascination du maître
espagnol pour ses objets rituels
cette ligne continue avec l'arête du nez
l'oreille qui est juste esquissé cette
oeuvre a été placée à côté ou en regard
d'un masque baoulé les quinze pièces
sont son véritable chef-d'oeuvre donc
sorte de de
presque de marquage en fait delà du
parcours de picasso d'oeuvres
emblématiques qui permettent de
comprendre les liens qui soit formelle
ou spirituelle ou des liens même
historique avec avec l'art africain des
archives retrace notamment la première
exposition de picasso à dakar en 1970 le
peintre n'a jamais mis les pieds en
afrique subsaharienne mais son lien avec
le continent est réel pour l'un des
commissaires de l'exposition
c'était à la fois une source
d'inspiration pour lui mais j'étais
également une source de réflexion de
déconstruction d'un certain nombre de
certitudes
arrivé brutalement à une production
aussi prodigieuse que c'est le moment
pour amplifier à dakar le projet mûri
pendant plus de cinq ans est le fruit
d'une collaboration entre quatre musées
sur deux continents
l'exposition picasso à dakar se tient
jusqu'au 30 juin prochain
est lui aussi exposé ses oeuvres des
photos de son nez le madagascar à
travers son objectif est d'un soul nous
en nous invite au coeur d'une pratique
ancestrale le vol d ai vu une tradition
depuis détournés si cette série en noir
et blanc début war qui a été primé par
la world press photo est azul bonsoir
bonsoir félicitations pour ce prix le
world press photo quelle a été votre
réaction à cette annonce
merci beaucoup pour votre vos
félicitations
ma première réaction évidemment c'était
très grande fierté de voir
un si long travail être récompensés par
un des plus prestigieux prix de
photojournalisme
et voilà et puis très grande fierté pour
madagascar aussi surtout
vous parlez de très long travail c'est
une enquête qui vous a pris huit ans il
me semble et il a fallu d'abord se faire
accepter dans ces régions reculées
oui effectivement ce sont ça m'a pris
c'est un travail que j'ai commencé en
2013 et
effectivement on peut pas arriver dans
ces endroits enclavées ou rencontrer ces
populations là comme ça
avec un appareil photo
avec le sourire aux lèvres
évidemment et nous rendre par de
négociation de discussions avant de
pouvoir faire sa première photo donc
mais ça c'est un peu le
comment dire des techniques
d'investigation de journalisme qu'il
faut qu'il faut maîtriser un minimum
quoi alors cette série de photos nous
faire entrer dans la guerre d'user du
zébu une tradition qui s'appelle dahalo
est-ce que vous pouvez nous raconter ce
que c'est
les dalles ou sons sont comment dire des
des bandes de voleurs de zébus qui est
effectivement
avant les années 2000 on va dire ce
cette pratique du vol début était plus
une pratique traditionnelle dans les
campagnes qui consistait à donc à voler
un début pour prouver une forme de
virilité
vis-à-vis de la fin que l'on convoite
mais depuis les années 2000 2010 ce
cette pratique l'année + devenue juste
une tradition c'est devenu un business
sortes de trafics qui qui qui jusqu'à
maintenant et toujours toujours en
vigueur et avec lequel l'état du mal à
se dépêtrer l'école a raconté dans quel
univers on se retrouve justement quand
on enquête sur le dalo
basse et c'est un univers c'est la
campagne déjà c'est la brousse profonde
où il n'y a pas de route il n'y a pas
d'électricité il n'y a pas de réseau
téléphonique
ce sont des zones très enclavée très
difficile d'accès
ces zones là ne sont accessibles que à
pied ou
donc
on est on arrivé là on il faut montrer
un peu patte blanche quoi ans comme je
vous disais au début on ne peut pas
arriver comme ça sans avoir au préalable
un peu discuté avec les chefs de clans
ou en tout cas avec une personne
notable
qui est un peu de pouvoir dans la région
qui puisse vous donner un peu une sorte
de laissez-passer pour pouvoir discuter
avec ces personnes là
c'est se sont aimés en même temps ce
sont aussi des paysages magnifiques
paradoxalement ce sont des c'est vrai
que ma série s'appelle
b2b wars la guerre des débuts mais ce
sont loin d'être des zones de guerre
comme on peut le comme on pourrait le
voir habituellement ce sont des paysages
magnifiques des
landes et des no man's land des endroits
auxquels on ne pourrait même pas
imaginer quoi qui pourraient exister
est-ce que ses habitants ont vu votre
travail qu'est ce qu'ils en ont pensé
non pour l'instant ses habitants n'ont
pas vu monter mon travail parce qu'ils
sont vraiment loin de tout
j'avais fait j'avais eu quelques
publications dont une danger au magazine
en 2020
mais on 2021 pardon mais voilà il
faudrait revenir là bas avec un
exemplaire du journal pour leur montrer
comment j'ai pu les photographier
comment j'ai pu parler d'eux
donc ça demanderait encore de refaire
toute la route tôt ça demande une
logistique particulière quoi donc pour
l'instant à moins qu'ils aient internet
qu'ils soient connectés sur les réseaux
de jeux je ne pense pas qu'ils ont
encore pu voir mon travail et après les
dahalo quels sont les autres thèmes que
vous explorez ou que vous allez explorer
bien pour le moment je travaille
beaucoup sur des des séries de photos où
je suis plus sûr plus sur une autre
spectre sion par rapport à
moi et ma relation à madagascar c'est un
travail que j'ai commencé déjà depuis
2004 mais je continue un peu et c'est un
travail qui a été exposée
notamment en 2019
la cité internationale des arts à paris
qui s'appelait malaga où je questionne
sur un sur un ton un peu de sociologues
d'anthropologues
quelle est l'identité malgache qui
sommes nous en tant que malgache malaga
c et b où nous allons quelles sont nos
projets de vie madagascar voilà donc
c'est un peu un travail au long cours
que je que je continue jusqu'à
maintenant et à côté de ça j'ai
évidemment mais mes reportages photos
[Musique]
notamment avec par exemple agence france
presse avec qui je collabore où tout est
dit opposé à madagascar
alors ce travail pour l'instant non je
ne sais pas le prix est vraiment la
nomination à ce prix est vraiment tout
frais c'était le 24 mars donc je n'ai
pas encore âgé encore rien organisé mais
évidemment ce serait génial si je
pouvais
exposé ce travail à madagascar
pour l'instant voilà il sera exposée à
amsterdam lors de la cérémonie de remise
des prix merci beaucoup et la soul et
encore félicitations pour votre prix le
world press photo
voilà c'est la fin du journal de
l'afrique merci de votre fidélité je
vous retrouve dans moins d'une heure
pour une nouvelle édition à tout à
l'heure
[Musique]